how are you JB great to see you here man
always great to see you here
how's life how things everything as well
as out of me everybody's doing
everybody's good you bat you're here in
the Midwest right boy here you are in
the Upper Midwest
it's neat seeing a Super Bowl here I
mean yeah interesting well I mean this
is cold is his coat was it to lose a
little code I think the NFL has always
tried to incorporate you know outdoor
activities yes with play 64 exactly so
it's a little challenging
except this weekend's play play minus 60
[Laughter]
and you're part of the Land O'Lakes farm
Bowl that's coming up tomorrow right
here in the afternoon and you're gonna
do it outdoors it's unbelievable oh no
wait a minute you're not it's it's
3m Arena it's the hockey arena yeah at
the University of Minnesota at the
University of Minnesota you and Luke
Kuechly Kyle Rudolph Golden Tate who I
saw last night golden dome er Greg
Jennings Jason Brown you're gonna be out
there just taking on each other right
perhaps so let's Stefon Diggs is also
involved as well and so we're going to
get with farmers yes now we're going to
be partnered up and we're going to do
these these these competitive challenges
that have a farm theme tune but those of
hay and drone drops and things like that
so it'll be pretty interesting I'm
looking forward to it because I have I'm
not a farmer by Nature I'm from Detroit
and all I know is concrete so for me to
to be involved in this it's it's been an
experience a learning experience for my
statement
that's neat well you know what's going
down tonight we have an annual tradition
here at the Rich Eisen show oh yeah
where we choose a night the whole group
goes out bowling are you free tonight
I need my to roll my ball
it's a casual bowler let's just go to
the lathe I'll pick a ball and play now
now hold on a second just to because I
will come to Jerome Bettis his defense
when NFL Network launched in 2003 as
soon as the season ended we were joined
in studio first player to join the NFL
Network in studio for extended days
guests on NFL Total Access was this man
Jerome Bettis and we decided let's do
stuff that Jerome likes to do we knew
you like to bowl and we told your own
we're gonna go bowling and he goes I
don't have my ball I don't have my shoes
and you had it shipped out absolutely
before we even went to go shoot the
piece dedication if you're a bowler you
don't go and just just you know you know
rent some shoes and get a ball you want
a bowl and so yeah that's the hardest
thing for me is it throw a straight ball
and and you know you can't just pass one
of those balls just you just any you
know it doesn't work I mean you know
it's like it's like an artist and you
give him a crayon he doesn't really want
to draw so really it's like you know um
if I pick up one of those balls I just
didn't how many how many 300 games I
have one 300 to get some 299 a bunch of
I threw it in a pocket I did everything
that I was supposed to do I did my part
you could imagine the disappointment
that was sick I was like physically sick
about that because you do all of that
you get to laugh right you roll it you
like oh that's it it's perfect what
stuff are rolling the 300 or we're
playing in the NFL stuff it takes a lot
longer to get to the NFL the gifting NFL
part is the hard part right the roller
than 300 you can do that and still be a
good bowler not a great book out you
a hall-of-famer Jerome Bettis here how
do you see Super Bowl 50 to play
announcer I think the quarterback has to
to win the game if you're the Eagles and
I think if you look at you know Blake
bortles you know he's a third and six
it's you know second quarter you take a
delay of game penalty causes them to go
out go down score get it get a ten point
game at half and then go out and win the
game in the second a half then you look
at Matt Ryan takes a sack when you just
can't take one if the quarterback makes
a mistake they're going to win the game
and the quarterback has to win the game
for the opposing team whoever that is
it's playing the Patriots so I think
Nick Foles has to win the game for them
and not necessarily with an incredible
performance but he can't make that
mistake that's gonna give the Patriots
another opportunity okay and how do you
think this is gonna play out with levy
on bail if anybody knows the business of
this league it's definitely you and you
know the Steelers as well how's this
playing out with levy on bail I would I
would think if I was if I was working
with lay down I would tell them you have
to understand they're sticking points
and so from the Stiller's standpoint
thirty years old is kind of like their
number they it's the law of diminishing
returns for them after you're 30 years
old so if you know that and if I'm late
on them saying I'm 27 I got three three
really more productive years I want to
capitalize on those so I want to get as
much money as I can get in those first
three years and then those last two you
can give me what you want to give me but
those first three I need to have 50
whatever it is 60 whatever it is I need
to get that in the first three years
that we can make a deal work and I could
be there and I think that also it goes
in line with Ben Roethlisberger I think
three years is he has that window of
being an elite quarterback for another
three years and keeping that group
together well do you think if levian
takes the approach of precedent setting
the precedent setting deal as in not
just the highest paid for running back
like he wants to seesaw
what Alex Smith just got from Washington
and wants something close to that do you
think that the Steelers are of mine to
set a precedent no I don't think I don't
think it's possible because of the other
players that you have on the on the team
you have arguably the best receiver in
the game period at the receiver position
yes you are arguably the best running
back at your position as well and the
president wasn't set there I don't think
the precedent is set here but I do
believe he needs to be the highest pay
running back any NFL no question because
I think he is the best running back in
the NFL when you look at his ability to
run and catch be a complete running back
he's the best okay so tonight this is
tomorrow the land olakes farm both go to
the farm Bolcom for more information
it's free if you're in town going out
there between 1:00 and 3:00 at the
hockey arena here on campus at the
University of Minnesota so just like the
fact that Notre Dame had to have its
feet held to the fire by Michigan to get
back on the schedule we need to pressure
you to just show up and Bowl without
your shoes in the ball already you
should be able to use any ball and
she'll be able to throw out just get any
shoes and he's choosing all just go out
there and you seriously you don't that's
you know that's that's like an archer
you know say hey just get up any ball
and just shoot any you know I'm not just
the average bowler sounds like he's
saying he's - I'm not a slice kind of
guy when I get out there
um I'm lacing them up I'm going to work
and I'm gonna talk about you know could
you and I combine yes beat Jerome Bettis
I think so
see that's therein lies the problem he's
thinking
thinks he thinks and goes bad he needs
to stick to the script stay in line
you'd really need to show up tonight
can we over can we get he's not good
that's the problem would you weak weak
so that's not he's an artist as we all
right and we're bad and we're and we're
drawing with a Crayola apparently to see
you at Jerome Bettis 36 on the Twitter I
follow me should as well the farm whole
calm for more information on hanging out
with jb see you soon but these you got
him Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience